okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is yet another episode
in our effort to document database
integration for version 12 of often
language and we want to start off
probably with the guide page here
so where had we left off last time we
were reviewing the working with
relational database guide we change we
rename some pictures and we are just
missing the description name and the
titles for entity class entity value
that we were not you were not sure how
to name it but also we've got all the
documentation for all these functions
right no I have not finish yes okay now
we also were starting the documentation
for oh boy
let's see entity store had a lot of
these I thought you were gonna change
these you didn't do that or do I need to
update now you didn't it wasn't in dad
like five minutes ago so okay fine funny
dad said I'm somebody I don't mention
that earlier um okay
stuff and then so that wasn't listed on
here yes returns to me no I mean that's
a nutter to do that was not new wasn't
new it's something we still have to do
right yeah yeah sure I think that that
lease was the added symbols
literally while you update the
documentation I want to ask you
something what do you think we should do
when a relational database expression
that has been returned from from the
connection gets manually edited by some
well man this isn't right either what
did you do here Tsukasa didn't do
anything but we just this just changed I
just know that Salle's entity store oh
oh oh oh oh oh sorry sorry sorry sorry
my confusion sorry what what are you
saying if something what so could you
perform the inspection on a database
connection and and you get an expression
that tells you a bunch of things about
the tables etc mm-hm what happens if
somebody takes that expression and
changes it yeah so I don't know and it's
the keys of the Association and so on
and so forth I mean that's an issue and
many of these object type things so I
have tentatively introduced something
that if you manually change it that it's
not valid queue anymore mm-hmm and I can
make it evaluate and return a failure if
you edit it saying you're you can
attempt it manually you have to
reinstate a bit I think that's fine I
don't see a problem with that in the
future we will allow that because
editing the relation object will will
actually trigger the same flag and say
maybe you need to do a migration and so
it will be the way to change the schema
of the database but you shouldn't
absolutely do it if you're just reading
I understand and I'm yes okay
I think it's fine okay so here you want
me to actually try and write this and
also we have to link this back to UM
[Music]
we've got another guide page right what
is the other guide page called database
for painting oh well that was good at
least I've correctly I'm okay then
actually I might as well produce that
link
okay okay so this page needs to be
redone a bit um
[Music]
stand that I don't understand that
comment I'm gonna delete this for right
now but I understand that comment um I
just don't understand I don't understand
these comments yeah okay fine um Andrea
you need to go back to whoever Andy QA
is dealing with this and unscramble us I
mean I it's not for me to do this okay
yet somebody - shall I delete this so
shall I leave this giant comments here
most of this is just confused
I think you can leave it there a nice so
I can't I can see what they mean for
that okay okay that's that's right
okay that's capable powerful
capabilities for working with many kinds
of databases um I think that's almost
all we can say because um yeah because
there's a lot of diverse stuff going on
on this page um so first thing is think
we want to say um I'd say I'm data
stores whatever that means and so the
first thing here is I don't think that's
really many types of X
journal databases including relational
paren SQL databases well now we've got
no SQL what what what are they called
document based databases you have
databases repeated external database
sometime I'm well aware yeah I'm all
aware um so I would say relational
triple stores for okay well what's [ __ ]
it's a document database right yeah so
document store an object store should we
say spa
cojiro as RDF for RDF is the store
Sparkle
well RDF by the way you've got him
somebody has a weird background rise
there
um relational database
abilities
well let's see um often language
entities stores are also closely
integrated with relational databases
allowing many operations specified in
the Wolfram language to be automatically
executed in external databases is that
useful to say I think that's useful but
it's not entirely true for most of these
guys I know that's why I say with
relational databases yeah but I meant
like for writing with relation to the
business we still only have database
link and that's not as tightly into it I
know allowing many how we could say
now assist operations that makes you
better feel better okay so first thing
that we have here is
I think we should say here we've got to
talk about data set now I mean how do we
think about
like [ __ ] and so on I mean what what
are they feeding into here if you
understand what I'm asking what do they
return did you understand the question
can somebody answer please there is not
right now being too rigid so no no no no
no that's not what I'm asking
I want to know what does it return what
what structure does it return
I see how do you get out you get your
own asking I want to know how do you get
data out from [ __ ]
I am not in position to the right I
don't think anyone here knows about
maybe I'm wrong
I think there's generally like
associations but alright could you
please try to adjust color your phone so
that you don't make okay should we
mention list an association here um
could somebody give yeah what should we
do here we should what is this I'm
trying to give people an idea what will
this data look like in our language
there are also the semantic objects like
date object and quantity that's a good
point
let's get I've been to buried if we have
like this big thing at the beginning no
no no we have to have this because
otherwise we can't position what we're
talking about later I mean this page is
a mess because it's going off in
multiple different directions okay but
well here okay so we're saying here um
here we're asking
was saying
based slash relational data /
knowledgebase so fair I mean it's a
little bit obscure but but um it's
trying to give some idea of what this is
makes sense to people yeah the other
thing you could say is that this is a
data container but probably no you bases
better
I don't know but it doesn't necessarily
contain the data
yeah source is wrong and to be based or
relational I hate using flashes like
that but then don't see relational I
mean I think it's useful to sell
relational here isn't it I mean and
entities are kind of naturally release
rightly figure okay
you
okay so this will point to our knowledge
representation page and all of that
stuff is around we want to mention
entity here
I think yes I think entity is important
although we might want to mention
entertai down below where we talk about
relational database operations fair
enough okay so this then points to the
page our general knowledge base
knowledge representation page do you
know number what it's called it's the
top level page
no nobody knows okay okay so this goes
away okay all right um so now we start
to say reading um or accessing oops
relational database information that
reasonable way to say it or or what you
know it's trying to make clear the fact
that it's not doing so that's now going
to be a summary of this page right I
think it's good enough for now and later
if we start writing when we start
writing we'll change this to something
like many bleeding information
okay by the way we also need to show on
this page the entity property form um
which I don't know I think we've shown
that on other pages so so Andrea you
have to figure out how to do that I I
don't know um
so here
probably something like entity of
property do you understand what I'm
saying it's it just needs to be
Department Department you're a CIA oh
right right right right right
so that's just um okay and that's
correct right that's the alternative
form for this is that correct guys
yes thank you okay
for um
I'm the basic relational databases is
mapped into entity stores operations on
entity stores
you
rather than I mean optimized seems like
a very big claim what's true we can we
can say instead of optimized something
like backends specialized or a light
well what about idiomatic okay okay okay
fine that's probably the best for
accessing computing with data in
relational databases there's a concept
it's a relation data in local or X or
remote relational databases is mapped
into entity stores operations honesty
stores defined symbolically and executed
using SQL code constructed at runtime
I'll say generated yes
generated using SQL code that is custom
generated or for each for any for any
standard database paren what are some
examples AG MySQL maybe see what may be
any supported database because we only
do that for the ones we saw okay an
excuse SQL could that is custom
generated for what are they my sequel
all of the databases I sequel SQLite
should SQLite be listed first maybe you
have to tell me how the capitalization
works because I don't know it my should
be M Capital y small and then SQL what's
next was gross SQL post Postgres no G's
small D small SQL like that yes
also ms SQL - ms SQL ms space a scale
I'm not sure that Postgres has twists it
has its cost well the website is
PostgreSQL like that okay you tell me I
don't know I've only seen no I think
capital capital 1 and its capital okay
and I and I think that ms SQL is
actually officially cool I mean they
call it SQL Server and just that but so
we should call it Microsoft SQL Server
SQL Server no there's a space okay you
guys can fix this okay what else what
other ones are that and we can say dot
dot you could say dot dot dot but I mean
we're not entirely sure yet that we can
bring in support for Oracle in verse 12
okay
okay rather than saying dot dot dot
maybe say and other support letters yes
now obviously since everybody's doing
some cloud version of these they all
have slightly different names SQL server
becomes sharor yeah I understand
okay okay fine all right okay so now
here
I think we want to be able to say
basically let me just pick out the ones
that we think we need from here it's
those two we'll need to change the names
as well oh it's already okay but below
you still have the old earnings I know I
know I know
Oh
you
okay hold on let's just try to figure
out
um
you
let's see um
you
let's say here
low level read/write low level SQL
readwrite database operations to make it
a little bit clearer away you might have
easy but you come every time to this
place and every time you see okay there
is update so we don't need to write I
know but I'm changing my mind okay
you
and this one is also read right correct
I don't think this is correct to say
here um
we do want to mention database dumps
right what does it important to can we
import an SQLite into something yet not
that way we have internals but we don't
have design there is no more import
format 4sq idea okay
but I mean we could well probably not
4:12 no database dump so by the way can
we export to a database dumper is that
not a useful concept is potentially
useful but that requires rewrite
operations don't export to a dump or to
add I think that is
I mean dumps are tricky really yeah yeah
then it still requires write operations
Carlo because the only right way to do a
dump is to specialize to a specific
back-end and use their own native dump
command yeah yeah yeah um by the way and
read these links are wrong these things
should be the special kind of links that
we offer a package same with these ones
here okay you said that already I think
this is only showing when you edit it
like that if you open it in product it
just okay okay fine all right here um I
should link to
I'm Andrea could you please ask Roger
again to fix this thing with the search
from open guide page opening the wrong
Finder window I'm talking about there I
don't know whether I can tell what I've
told them three times already so
hopefully when you tell them again he'll
figure out okay great um okay so um
let's see you don't necessarily have to
use dead based reference to you or do
you I know it's not necessary
okay so let's not document that here
because um
um symbolic representation of a
connected relational database and it
does won't be correct
why not because this thing doesn't
necessarily say that the database has
been connected okay
okay well how about that pen I still
want to get into every detail of every
particular thing here
you
yeah
okay now
you
I think we need this and then we need I
think entity function is a key thing
here to give an idea of how this
possibly works
okay and then let's just give a few
samples of these are the ones which are
your favorites filter the entity class
yeah that one definitely also extended
entity class is that comprehensible here
I think we want to say this sort of
aeration okay
I think we should say aggregated here
because I think it's an easier word to
understand what it might possibly mean
and this is only a you know an attractor
for people that should go click on the
next page because they're not gonna get
all the information here and the next
page is one you have on the right yeah
okay
okay these need to be tagged as version
12 I suppose I can do it like I can do
it this doesn't mess up amazing that's
not 12 actually that's a 12 12 tilde ah
then work okay so um Andrea can you deal
with that that the entity class until
now you need 12 tilde type things to
indicate change and this oh for goodness
sake not this bug again could you report
this bug and then go fix this right you
saw what it did yes yes I said the book
okay okay
all right great all right modified in 12
um okay let's go back now if I'm
understanding correctly knowledge
representation access do we need that
one as well yeah that's the page
oh yeah we should mention data drop on
this page shouldn't we
well maybe not maybe not ah
let's see where where was the knowledge
base page that was in so we already
changed this to have identity function
and things like that on it although it
didn't correctly mark it for 2012 um
okay we already have this um okay so
here
you
let's see I think we need a section here
that's called external database this
page is a bit of a mess by now
that wants to link to database
operations whoops oh gosh it's called
database connectivity um and actually
that's probably a better name for it
okay and now on this page also let us
put um links to
you
you
I don't know whether we want to have
links to these packaged things like
database Explorer [ __ ] Connect I'm
gonna put these in here just as a way to
get people to UM to these other things
you
I mean I would argue maybe that Sparkle
execute is a useful thing to have in
here because that's something you might
want to do as part of the knowledge
representation
you
a little bit of a mess but I think
that's okay and these need to obviously
be the package um the problem Stephan is
the sparkle execute is a function that
actually does something that's the
execution while the other things here
are more representation self these
storages stores well let's put this
underneath them it's just useful because
people who are thinking about knowledge
representation they might very well care
about this it goes along with all of
these other
maybe then you could also put entity
value alongside because we've already
got entity value way up above here okay
you
but in a slightly the other way ways
from go ahead I'm sorry yes it's in a
different context
so I'm saying in some cases you can also
sorry but we're not gonna repeat it on
this page this page is kind of a mess
and polish should be rewritten okay but
we're not going to do that right now
ah I mean arguably this should go ahead
and link to the page
working with relational databases even
though in this situation they're not
dealing with relational databases right
they're dealing with local in in memory
things which also work right yeah it
doesn't say here or whether but but the
question is whether we linked to that
place it's a generic knowledge thing we
shouldn't link to relation because we
need to people can't find information
about those functions okay let's go back
here to deal with these functions okay
so you've got entities store here um so
what what exactly do you want me to do
here so we've got we've got a list of
things here
okay so did okay and read which of these
are we working on which of these were
already done we are not done with
anything yet we have started like I used
to put asterisks but then I think I was
confusing you because they are not done
okay okay okay so so none of these pages
are done it's what you're telling me yes
okay this is not going to done done
meaning not not you haven't approved but
I think design wise they're in
reasonably good shape I think so okay I
mean changing the design now which would
be sweet sighs oh well except last time
you're telling me it took you 20 seconds
to change no that's that's not change in
design just okay okay whatever
okay um okay enter the store all right
let's okay where we're gonna go here
we're gonna look and you didn't listen
to the store unfortunately well that's
not new there's no but you've made
changes to its relation so which other
things have we made changes to
in TD class at least and we glass I'm
not sure unknown yet let's take a look
so please let's okay enter the
carcinogen list when do we ever get to
do random entity and num you know that
that's something we should support for
these databases is there a reasonable
way to do it it's complicated it's it's
I mean it's really not very easy to do
quickly because he sometimes you need
the food tables can to do it we will
think about it but it's it's a generally
known to be a complicated problem isn't
that something databases have an
intrinsic function for doing no that's
why it's complicated I say so though you
basically a counter at least can't you
at least um just look at the IDS and
just sort of pick a random ID
what do you mean picker and so the thing
the way people do this is usually like
be they generates random number and then
by sort they sort by them but if you
were just getting two things out of a
very large table then that's very
deficient I understand why why not do
something where I think on isn't there
an efficient operation to just get the
nth element out of a table and tell it
by ID out of a table ah still
insufficient if the column which you are
questing has an index and you know but
since we can't right now change the
schema and we work with what we are
given in general if someone didn't take
care to take the make the index then
we're out of luck right so we can't
assume that right okay primary keys are
normally in medicine they're always a
list okay let's start off the identity
store
okay I what does this mean what does
this first line mean Tony little data
there's no data the real it becomes
really useful if you want to start with
an empty there's an empty store that has
multiple types and then fill it up using
assignments of the form entity of
property equals value oh I see represent
I didn't read the word empty properly
here okay
with properties and values defined by
data okay for entities and multiple
types okay
now constructing as you saw from the
schema of an external database okay that
seems fine to me
oh my gosh what leg is that
this is buggy no it put that in the
wrong place
how did you get that I don't know it
jumped to the wrong place so Carlos
there this is something you gotta fix
okay okay I have no idea how that
happened or even why it happened or
anything but that history editor what is
that oh I brought it up it's a more info
editor it's part of the airplane cockpit
of doctor tools interesting um okay
relational database object so that isn't
correct from the schema this is just
relational database open/close right and
database connection that this reference
no it's done of is reference read there
I don't think we want it in this place I
think we want generally you want to be
specifying the schema here do it you
said that the the whole like pipeline
was crazy and since I mean if you
specify the the just reference then we
perform automatically the the schema
inspection and then we can construct the
entity store so it was a convenience
well so relational database is
equivalent but that that one let's let's
say
hmm
okay so wait a minute what should we put
up here I don't think we want to
separate lines here the basically will
say the same yeah but listen there's a
good reason for that if in the following
one where you specify what what tables
you want to expect if you have a very
large database by going through the
connection and not the full schema you
you you save a lot of time because you
can instruct the inspection just to
check those tables and not everything I
I understand that I understand that so I
think you can I think what is going on
here this thing is I don't know what
this is doing um and I don't know what
that did there that was totally weird
okay this is really broken it's really
broken okay you got to fix this right
and make sure it's fixed like today
don't leave it broken okay yeah but yeah
so my point was that it's it's important
to document also the just a connection
just a reference because you can you can
make more lazy inspection in that case
um not inspect everything
I understand but that's the case where
you want a DB spec here wants to be then
database reference the case where you
just say blue database reference is
equivalent to this case yes it is right
so we can leave it the way this right
now okay what's this so you wanted me to
just move a lot of those users messages
in the details so I just call it
metadata and then lower down
how does it relate to what's what's in
here it's similar but he in shape but it
never contains any data while there it
contains data
doesn't define properties and values
okay okay fine but here we didn't give
the other line here where you give T
spec arrow data and so on right I think
that spec there is meant to mean type
goes to data
or just type either type or type goes to
date
well then let's say T spec here let's
say
let's do the same thing here
um isn't the data provider always the
second argument and if this is the case
why data is not always as I do not
remember I know that for backward
compatibility we need to give it also in
the first one but it can make sense the
augmented Zealand I'm sorry what are you
talking about data is this like pure
data for in-memory store no it's not
pure data what Riccardi saying is that
there is a part of the original
specification for the entry store which
come which is entities and contains an
association of business association yeah
it also contains metadata and so what
Ricardo was saying if we're saying that
the data at least four databases the
data is in the second argument and the
metadata is in the first wouldn't make
sense for that structure to separate
what is data and what is metadata and
move the data to the second argument
like it would be more consistent with
what we're doing for with databases but
what would the structure of the second
argument be the structure a second
argument would be exactly what is on the
right hand side of entities right now
they're just an association with the
basically canonical item that's obvious
it's la Tony what I mean we don't get to
do that today but what is Tony's opinion
about that I think it's a nice thing
that you could do okay fine
okay so then unifies with the database
mechanism
okay so let's just say here T spec 1t
spec 2
DB speck
um constructs an entity store
[Music]
with
types
you
let's see by mapping table names in the
database to types by mapping table names
in the database specified by DB spec to
types as specified and by T spec one by
the T spec I you okay with that mm-hmm
so for consistency I think that argument
should be either list or non list do you
mean you can just have a string map yes
at least that should be allowed yeah I
agree it should be allowed I think it's
sufficiently rare I don't think it's
worth putting it in the top-level
documentation here but I agree it should
be allowed okay okay
now okay
okay so this supplies only
you
unless permission to set otherwise foot
unless permissions are set otherwise for
well we can leave that statement I think
when we start writing to databases maybe
we will need to qualify it a little bit
more
well obj can be many other things here
right it can be a whole entity function
structure and so on
I guess not currently okay
oh yeah the entity function doesn't have
properties but you can do if a BJ's
entity is filtered into the class then
you can get properties of none yes
you
okay so
I don't know what any of these things
are Tony is this something real that we
have to worry about or not no I'm not
for now
and some of them are obsolete I can
clean them up
you
you
okay oh my gosh okay we've got a number
of questions on the live stream let's
take a look at these michael says
there's a concept called reservoir
sampling to take a small random sampling
from large data set I don't I don't know
about that
um as an efficient way to take top and
elements based on a sort without sorting
the entire column
yeah I think some the beauty of SQL is
that it's a very high-level language and
so you never know how the query is
actually going to be executed so I'm
pretty sure that some backends when the
column is indexed allow for efficiently
doing that but I would not guarantee
that that that happens all the times for
all columns on all backends okay is a
way to pull an entire database out into
data set the answer is yes but I'm not
sure I mean I'm not sure how good that
workflow is right now I mean if you do
an import so let's say we've got a
relation on so that's a good question
we've got let's say it's a small
relational database and we just say I
want to go p-- the whole thing into a
single data set how do I do that the
problem is in a single data set you
can't because typically you will have
several related tables and let's see you
only have one table very serious yeah
it's empty value the name of the type so
the name of the table comma the data set
but if the database already has like two
tables and they are foreign keys
pointing to one another the data set
representation no it's not hopeless but
the data sets representation would be
poor because it doesn't it doesn't look
like they represent the foreign keys or
what yeah for example but then the
entities you know will not will be just
dangling references they're not have
rupes
it's hierarchical well it cannot have
loops so far but we may have loops on
the love all the crap or language I
think we'll need to discuss it in a
separate session because obviously at
some point we'll have to start compiling
data sets index also to SQL write still
compiling data sets to SQL
you mean yeah you exporting a dataset to
an SQL queries to SQL for that it's
possible I don't know whether it's
desirable I mean I think that you know
our compiler for our language may be a
better way to handle that no no that's a
different that's a different topic the
world many requests from the users and
you repeatedly ask this question whether
one would be able to query like to have
datasets pointing to database tables and
then query those tables using data set
query language okay so our point is that
these questions about how one would
represent the entire database of several
tables as maybe several data sets is
related to those kind of problems so we
should discuss it in a separate session
okay but the thing you just mentioned
which you attributed to me correctly of
using data set query language on an SQL
database is a different thing and has
nothing to do with foreign keys quite
different it's certainly related to
foreign keys why I mean that have to do
with foreign keys but if you ignore
those operations data set query language
does not have foreign key capabilities
it's it's some it's so far yes right
okay but to support its already super
interesting to support existing data set
query language against an SQL database
well but it would be frustrating because
most of the things that data set can do
we cannot do in SQL and most of the
things that are interesting about well
I'm not sure I completely buy that but
okay okay all right
I think the covers an interesting
prototype of something that and and
Loney had a working prototype but yeah
whatever has happened to Lin it's out of
core-list operation thing so there are
those just hibernating right now
yes Steven there were a few technical
problems but I am waiting for the time
the good time to discuss it with you
again okay all right fine um Karl on
livestream points out that set up an
entity store workflow needs to be
updated
andraia that's for you
check that okay apparently the setting
up an entity store right now is pure
in-memory stuff and it needs to be
updated to deal with the the relational
database case which is as Karl says
likely to be the most interesting one um
okay
oh boy this is a lot of material here
I think in the first one the meta is
missing Association can have the [ __ ]
no the the met up expression it's not
necessarily Association hold on hold on
hold on
well first thing we have to do here
oh my gosh
could you please do an update of this
with all the modern stuff like instead
of combined and merged into classes that
are sure sure
you
Michael on the livestream is clarifying
what reservoir sampling is
um
okay all right that's this let's let's
just scope out what we have to do
so this oh boy what do we have to change
an entity class some things I think that
the thing that has changed entity
classes that the first argument it means
not necessarily a string in the second
usage message not in the first so well
this doesn't even have this is something
completely different right entity class
okay yeah this can gobble up all the
other class like things second one at
least no but wait a second the second
argument there can be what no no no no
no the second argument in modern times
what can that be is it always of this
form yeah or a string another way I
don't know we need another case here the
the first usage of message-id on a white
name is not a string because it's always
a string as far as I know it's not
always a string can be a list okay
you
wouldn't that be in the other cases
reuse class there and the glass of glass
okay okay so now what does the set work
and the second argument B what is the
second argument
does it even need a second argument
catkin yes okay what is the second
argument only the the one in the second
usage message no but you said it could
be a string as well what is what kind of
no no no youyou decided that we should
not have the string version nest like
that so if you're using actually class
counter eg8 you cannot wrap it around
filter dance class you have it the other
way around
oh yeah
what can the second argument B list of
rules property goes to predicate
should it be predicates rather than
value there absolutely because those are
it's much more useful when those are
predicates and the case where it's a
value maybe you know maybe leave it
there for type but the the when there is
a value that basically implies equal to
or contains oh I guess Tony can speak to
that but the value is a special case of
a predicate tree yes okay
I always say object don't think that
that's
um represents an
implicitly defined
and to class
um
whose members
have properties property i satisfying
predicates predicates pred i right
that's right
Africa Messiah implicitly
don't cone but why should the usage
messages be different in the second and
third line well to give some indication
that they're different things or I mean
why should in the one case the value and
then he had a predicate if they're
actually the same well because we're not
saying everything here
because we can't but I agree with Tony
this really looks confusing still people
may think that the only values are
supported for the upper case and the
only break is for the lower I I think
that we should just subsume the second
in the third yes
yeah so we should put Brad's also in the
second hello we should just now oh just
do it yeah yeah okay I think that would
be reasonable
so the first argument put could be type
not string by the symbol their type is
either type or a class no no look you
got to decide do you want it to say
class you want to say type here
I wanted to see class I think so too I
think we just delete this case here
but then the usage method should mention
class somehow
well I how would you like to mention
class its covers their complicated thing
here
yeah I don't know okay let's start from
the beginning again
you
also no no no just a second just a
second just a second
you
let's see what we really are saying here
is that this is a subclass of class I
don't understand why this is different
from filtered entity class it's it's
different
because for two reasons first of all is
that this guy here can only do end of
those predicates and you cannot have a
predicate involved with multiple
properties at the same time secondly
this also actually takes things that are
not predicates like large take largest
whatever it is okay you know what guys
okay look this is a sensible line to
have here because it explains what's
okay um represents an officially defined
entity class containing entities of the
specified type for which why not wait a
minute the properties property I have
values go ahead what at this point we
can put class in this one as well
no no because we got to anchor it to
something right as soon as we say class
here what are you gonna say how are you
gonna describe that the string type he's
a he's a class I I know I know I know
but we're going to explain it this way
so that people if you say class they're
all right okay so hold on I think I've
got another way to do this okay I think
I got a way to do this all right so now
here
I think this is going to be not totally
stupid okay watch
hey that's formatted wrong by the way
and rare that's formatted wrong the
double quotes are wrong Andrea yes I'm
looking at so I think I will just report
all the formatted oh now don't report it
that I'll fix them and it's not
necessarily a bug it's not a bug at all
or it's not a bug it's just that we're
not able I'm not typing them correctly
because I'm trying to not spend all my
time typing the thing okay I mean I can
do it but I hacking around here
pleasedon't here we go
you
then wait wait wait wait wait just a
second please okay we can get this to
work
just hold on I was just saying that
predicate is not correct why not
because take largest is not a predicate
okay don't don't then what should we
call this I don't know because a to me
it was a mistake to introduce take
largest in there and we know we're in
the details we explain what happens when
you have multiple take largest okay well
which is take largest is works because
okay so let's call it a selector then
so Donnie I think you should add you
should enter that a detail thing go
obviously he has to write okay but it's
a hollow thing represents an apostle
define entity class for which
you
I mean we could also turn everything
into this The Selecter thing
let's specify type for which the
his butt
um
you
correspond to the value selectors
you
we could say correspond to the value
selectors let's say v-spec 1 2 etcetera
etcetera
you
how about this conformed to the value
selectors b-spec I
and then we can say what the possible
value selectors are
comments
yes
okay now
you
then we say here
and a class represents an implicitly
defined entry class
you
you
um
you
I forgot a sec oh my gosh
okay so here we've got to say what the
initial thing there is
based on
five buzzword in which presents an an
entity class
you
based on the specified
she's back
you
um
you
painting numbers okay I think I have it
implicitly defined entity class
containing members
you
hey wait wait wait wait wait wait leave
it okay it's not great
go ahead now what you don't say I wanted
to say that the adverb implicitly in the
brave new world of filtered antique
glass and coal is probably useless okay
represents an entity class containing
members
you
you
well
that it's not I mean I think we just
have to then describe what all these
things are and frankly this is not going
to be the place where you can learn the
stuff immediately
you
okay is this correct you got to go
through every single note here and
figure out what's what's correct I don't
think that's correct anymore by the way
we I remember you said that single
entities that are computed from
databases shouldn't format differently
but we've never talked about how all the
new heads should format and I think that
they should not try to hide too much and
and what currently what implicit entity
class does is probably the wrong thing
well I'm sorry what what are you talking
about here okay take a new notebook type
entity class country and then population
goes to blah and then make another one
with population goes to something else
they all look the same they all say
countries and nothing
so you're saying entity class yeah I
think that's wrong
I agree country let's say population
arrow greater than and then put hash and
map is over range of something yeah I
understand I understand
um ten to the power range of eight nine
whatever it is
unless you're wrong Oh
that is utterly obscure Tony would you
like to comment on that I agree
so my wait-wait-wait-wait-wait so the
issue is should they close up should I
mean the issue is that they've closed up
there
right that's that's one issue the other
issue is what do you do if you had a
filter density class here so let's
imagine that I did this
I said filtered entity class
and then here I said I want to what do I
want to do I want to filter it by let's
say entity function of country comma um
its capital city in pollution something
like that well I'm just gonna say
population I'm just gonna I'm sorry well
no cccc sorry see a population less than
10 to the 8 which is going to remove
certain not learning of the unpleasant
thing within the answers function
you
okay all right here we go so this should
be
the heck is this now so this if I try to
resolve these with entity list I should
get you might need to map entity some
again I did I notice I did got nothing
okay so what did I do wrong here
filtered entity class of country comma
entity function population less than 10
to the 8th I think that's all good
do I need to say 10 to the 8 people oh
maybe but that's not what went wrong
with entity list ok ok so now what so
this didn't indicate that this displayed
nothing special so now what
why can't that resolved with entity list
Tony did you implement this new usage
message okay so that's why it's not
implemented yet forensic class then I
explained to me Tony but you're gonna do
this right yes
okay so the Cooper the question is
something like filtered entity class
here let's take this one here I think
wait wait wait wait wait wait that that
just displays like this right
sorry what we're gonna say well what I
was going to say is that and single
entities format to a specific thing
because we are trying to hide under the
rug the canonical name which might be
something that people shouldn't really
not care too much about named entity
classes same same story all these
constructs including implicit entity
classes are our code are things people
are going to type they're not something
that they'd only get from control equal
and so I I think that there is no good
argument for this stuff to format in any
special way okay so if I say countries
with population above 100 million
you
oh boy that's even a different way that
there so this is a good way this is a
good thing we did right see this this
formats fine you understand what we what
just happened here
yes no well it just displace your input
string yes yes yes SSSs but that's in
order to deal with okay in order to deal
with this issue have you typed something
in and then you can't see what you typed
in I softer case because no I know
because it's what we typed in and we
didn't have a thing we typed in right
you can see that here when we evaluate
this it goes to something which does not
show the the result that what you kind
of say Tony yes so we can't generate the
process possible input no of course not
of course not of course not that's the
issue entirely true I do generate no no
no we can't generate a natural language
string that represents this okay that's
what Tony was trying to say so the issue
here is in this case for example
with this form of implicit entity class
we are showing the yellow box with this
form of implicit entity class we are not
right with this one we are not right and
your point is that's piece of code and
it will be silly to try to hide it under
something
and I generally agree with that but when
it's inside an entity class it's going
to get incredibly complicated to see all
this stuff
um
what is that my somebody just sent me
something
Carlo did you just send me something
here yeah and trying to send you
something
I send it to ya look at you saw that so
I have spent a lot of time doing
networking with generation for this
stuff and it is possible many cases oh
and true a country with a population
greater than what has people capitalized
them because I that's what I get out
softer oh they don't I don't believe
that's correct I believe there's a
there's a string version of that but
isn't I can try and find it but if you
dad's to do a request well father and I
can choose it gets too slow well okay so
why don't you ask the people who deal
with units about now yeah but this is
like interpreter has you can put
whatever you want there in terms of
restriction I will try to generate
something reasonable for a Europe by the
way do those restrictions correspond to
the implicit entity class yes diligence
they do is that documented anywhere yes
it is and and I think that we probably
can update it to use entity function as
a filter as well may be restricted
should be part of what's mentioned here
I mean it's an interest
question whether restricted is a word
that could be used inside entity class
see what I'm saying that's scary yeah no
but you see what I'm saying because
that's that's basically explicitly
naming the operation that's going on
here implicitly in entity class
you could pull out the thing that's
inside the entity class without it
explicitly being mentioned as an inter
class we're out of time here um
this thing about formatting needs to be
thought about and that effects you know
implementation as well as just
documentation for whatever it's worth
they think that we should lose that
format from your masses on now is that's
called - I'm sorry what are you talking
about that that's formatting for a
please identity classes I think should
not be there I think they should just
show us next because they are called
like I want 20 that I want to change
10th one hundred thousand to ten
thousand oh yeah this is a separate
issue this is a separate issue I
understand what you're saying
I don't know Tony do
about that
somehow I like to see more information
and they'd like it to be edible editable
yes I do Bo and I think I personally I
think it's much better if it's edible
sorry
mother that could be a complicated
presentation that also allows editing
for that might be complicated
why did we lie to this case this case
here
my guess is a historical reason like all
the other things were alighted and like
if you come from the direction of single
entities and named that the classes
makes perfect sense if you come from
reflexion filter that's it class then I
guess this is like their I thank you for
let me I think I'd be useful to ask
Michael his opinion of this I mean I
think it's gonna be very very confusing
if
what happens is that this just stays
unavailing
I think it's going to give some
indication that it understood what you
were talking about I think it's gonna be
super confusing if the thing just stays
unevaluated until you explicitly say you
know whatever it is here so this
but what happens if I say random entity
of percent 20 comma 5
huh
okay that's nice
okay separate topic please talk to
Michael about this and see whether we
can come up with a way to format the
output from this so that it is not
you know so it has changed in some way
from the input but nevertheless still
understandable and editable so make
sense to people
yes okay I need to go but this comment
from Carl on the live stream the are
post GIS and
positions natively
you
no it's not something we have right now
yet there are there are extension of
Postgres that allow you to do really
well I I know we we use those those
things that's what our geo servers use
now guys we are getting confused what
what Carl Lang is talking about this
stuff that we already use internally for
the cheer server and it's completely
separated from what posture starts with
GIS systems we know the trio server is
using post Gus
no not Postgres plus GI yes I think so
isn't it our an extension of no I think
so it's I post GIS is it turns out my
brother is a you urban planner and so
it's it's like doesn't have anything to
do with databases it's just for geo
stuff no that's a different thing you're
thinking of things like ArcGIS and so on
that's a completely different thing it's
not what we're using so what we use is
an extension to Postgres that is for GIS
stuff and that's what we use for things
like geo nearest that's what's that's
what's happening in the and it's an
interesting possible yes I stand
corrected
because essentially it is an extension
of those base
yeah okay so um
[Music]
testing point I mean we clearly have I
mean that would be basically supporting
boy I mean we have things like see the
issue then is what we've got is a
different it's a different back-end that
supports a different set of things in an
entity function basically because it
would support things like geo nearest in
entity function which a typical
relational database doesn't have a hope
of dealing with but yes we do have that
technology I mean it's an interesting
thing you guys could talk to after this
stuff is done you could talk to
Francisco who's been dealing with the
dealing with that stuff for the geo
servers I mean we just did this big new
update of all the geo servers so I think
it's they're fairly clean and modern
um and that would be a good idea I mean
does that make sense to you guys that
that's then it's a relational GIS
database is then an alternate back end
just like Oracle might be a back-end and
so on that right
yeah sure I mean it's an immediate
technology people are using it yeah yeah
mostly not okay all right good stuff
we're gonna have to follow this up yet
again um and hopefully one of these days
my cough will be gone
um the
why are we seeing things I'm seeing an
update darks update and their things
like spatial point data I don't think we
were getting that for this version
anybody know anything about that I'm
sure you guys don't know anything about
that
Wow that's spatial statistics stuff I
didn't think we were getting that for
version 12 maybe this isn't for version
12 maybe this is for beyond version 12 I
just happened to notice that term
supercool okay
ha I saw over a bunch of overachievers
already have examples for things that
are not going in 12 is making us look
bad with the same yo yeah right okay
alright good stuff
see you soon thanks to folks on the
livestream for your comments bye